i got punked by trying to stick up for a
woman by the way i just reminded me when
you said the
oh for she was like getting slapped
around he stuck out you got slapped
around very
not all not that i didn't get slapped
around but i i definitely
turned into a [ __ ] i i was driving this
wasn't that long ago
i was driving home ironically from muay
thai i was driving home
and uh i'm pull up to um rose in lincoln
in venice
there's that whole foods there yeah and
behind it there's like the loading dock
and i'm just driving like at a stoplight
and i'm just minding my own business
getting ready to go home
and i look over and these two homeless
people arguing
not at all surprising or new for venice
california
all of a sudden it's a guy girl and all
of a sudden he just
[ __ ] boom front kicks
this is venice right to her chest and
she falls down
whoa so i without even thinking i almost
impulsively i i threw my car in park and
i i got i was like hey
and he turns around and goes like and
his like
[ __ ] missing teeth and [ __ ] and he
wasn't like big guy but
like he turned and he looked like a
zombie you're gonna have your hands full
and not only that
in my mind in the in a matter of a
second all these thoughts go through i
was like
am i really to put hands on this guy who
definitely has the diseases
polio and you know and this is prayer
prior to
covet or anything but then i'm like
really what am i am i going to just
head kick him and hope for the best and
run away and then i was like
hey be cool you can't do that
that was my what he's like as an after
school special i was like you can't do
that
by the grace of god there's some uh
dudes who worked for whole foods in like
the loading and and they had their
little walkie-talkie things
and they come over and they're like
we're calling the cops right now we're
going
he's like [ __ ] [ __ ] and he just
runs away but in my heart i was like was
the girl
i thought i was jason stated and then i
was like
what do you want anything i'm thinking
like i'm the man i'm going to go over
i'm going to help her out she's probably
yelling
like she did you think she's jesus yeah
eat [ __ ] i do you want better
my buddy is your friend in france
studying muay thai
my buddy george and his buddy and his
friend is really like
taking it very seriously and they're in
paris beautiful city
sure and there's a guy attacking a woman
against a car
and uh my friend's buddy
goes over and goes i do muay thai
kicks him in the [ __ ] leg elbows him
punches him the guy [ __ ] falls down
but
the guy's not that good he's not that
athletic the guy goes what the [ __ ] are
you doing
and the guy he was hitting was the
brother
of that woman who was having a diabetic
seizure
and he was trying to hold her down and
control her
and so oh my god and that guy went to
the hospital
and so my friend my friend's friend
brought him flowers every day
and said sorry but he was in the
hospital for three days [ __ ] uh but you
know so you gotta be careful no you
definitely she was having a diabetic
seizure it was just like that's my
[ __ ] sister she's having
in like regular life i've gotten in so
few
physical altercations but i can
so rarely think of any that went well
for me like
yeah one one time i i absolutely uh a
blit uh hit a home run without face
and totally cheap shot at him but it was
worth it um and
i still feel totally good in doing and
i've told this story
on the air enough that i now feel
comfortable saying without getting like
charges brought against me but um prior
to
marijuana being fully legalized in
california it was just medical
stuff so in venice there there's just
tons of dispensaries
and they all had these guys who were out
in front like trying to promote their
said just go get your medical card come
get your medical card
and there's this guy he was big he
wasn't in good shape but he was big
person a big kind of fat and uh he's
like hey man get you
come get your your medical card and i'm
walking my dogs i was like i'm
i'm okay man it's cool and he's like oh
what what god you got that pink lugs
little [ __ ] got pink lungs and i'm like
uh no i just
a little [ __ ] yeah and it's a saturday
in summer in venice there's
thousands of people around yeah and i'm
like i know i i just don't
smoke weed so he's like oh yeah you
don't smoke you're not man enough to
smoke weed
ain't got any hair on your chest and and
he starts now he starts doing like a
like a defensive back
if i'm a wide receiver i'm walking like
this and he's like this
like as i'm trying to cut you off yeah
watching your hips
[ __ ] kind of and so i got
i got like uh overwhelmed with like
almost like fear like
this guy's trying to figure it out yeah
and so i put
my dog's leashes into my left hand and i
just went
wham and just cracked him full swing as
he's looking away trying to get people
to pay attention to him punking me
and i just cracked him not even over not
even looking at me and i just [ __ ]
cheap shot and right
and he he did i didn't knock him out but
he fell down and i could tell he was
seeing
his guards like and i go did you run
away and i go oh my god i just committed
felony assault in front of thousands of
people and i
take my let's start sprinting away it
was like those signs you see when you're
going to mexico where the
family's getting dragged behind my poor
dog's like and i just ran away and i
went home and i was like oh [ __ ]
and i never told anybody about it for
like a year and then i went on love line
i
opened up and i was waiting a fat guy if
it's a fat white guy
i'm not going to be intimidated yeah if
he's samoan yeah i'm going to be afraid
i'm never going to fight publicly the
closest
that if i ever do get a fist the cuff
ever is on the bike
trail these bikers it's not mountain
bikes mountain bikers are great mountain
bikers
they got they stay in their lane
everyone does their own [ __ ] it's the
people in the tight spandex and they're
on like
the road bike but it's on the mountain
bike they just for whatever reason
they always yell at people or you know
you shouldn't have your headphones in
the yell if you don't have a mask on
like they always say something that's
that's and especially like if i'm going
through something someone yells i'm like
ah
dude there's nobody around but what do
you think
you would do somebody if you had to
fight a guy like that
would you choke him or squeeze him or
would you punch him
i'd punch him right in the face you
would yes and then get on my bike i'd
take his bike
i'd throw it off the mountain and then
get online and keep going
who's the guy though that when you i'm
telling you oh dude
all the time oh that guy's got everybody
every time i write they're on their bike
to say
something take your headphones off
what do you care what you have to do is
go look at my ears it's not going to
work out for you that's
it no i just i just pretend i don't hear
them i keep going but every it's only
those guys in the
the in the spandex and like the right
hand there was a guy in
marina del rey i used to see i'd be
walking my dog this [ __ ] guy
probably 50 very big
very good shape bald head looked like a
like a cop of some kind and such a dick
he was right he would ride people he's
just he was got to be probably 6'4 but
with those long legs just a b you'd have
your hands full
and he was such a dick and he was in the
he would always be in his bike
and cars were going hey [ __ ] face watch
yourself
and he was so aggressive and every day
i'd have my dog and i'd be like
i would have to fight him well brian
kell would have to fight him i'd have my
hand folded might get my ass still
but i just hated him so much it's a
special kind of person to speak i'm like
yeah i was like just bullying just get
your work out
shut the [ __ ] up right well it's like
there's there's one trail i go down
it's you go by this cool it's in santa
monica mountains you go by
they have this old world war ii post
it's dope it's
it's way high and then you go down the
mountain and then to the left is the
bike trail where
it is straight for biking no one walks
it everyone knows the bike trail
you go up and it's down there's jumps
and like it's fantastic
and this dude's walking with this hot
ass shoe so hot that's how i notice them
they're walking hand in hand and they're
on the middle of the bike trip with a
bike it's a single track
i can't go left i can't go i don't want
to die so i'm like watch out and the guy
was like
[ __ ] you bro we're walking here and i'm
just looking i'm like
what what he's just i'm like what are
you thinking dude
what's gonna happen man if you've
probably talked [ __ ] like this your
entire life and no one's ever done
anything that's
that's why you're doing it that's why i
jump off this bike
man you know what i don't know i think
part of like training
in anything like yesterday malik was
holding mitts for me
and then he started hitting me back with
the mitts and
what i realized i don't know this is
gonna be shocking to you is that i'm not
able to do anything against him when he
starts doing that because
he can hit me everywhere and he's been
doing it since he was seven
and when you do that with a guy who's
what's mark 165
yeah and then and he can kill me yeah
and then i look like and i like this
stroll
yeah but he can knock you the [ __ ] out
no no
with his [ __ ] hands and then i look
at you and i go
when you're a regular dude and you've
been training and you see those ears and
you see the size of them you go
oh that's going to be a disaster that's
not good
all right take all the ufc take all that
away but just
it could be anywhere i agree dude why
don't be that disrespectful you don't
know who you're [ __ ]
no you just but also like you you saw me
coming a mile away
just step to the side dude why do you
want problems well that guy that guy
definitely doesn't train and secondly
has never really got his ass
no because you you just you you learn
quickly
i i'm i'm not uh
advocating violence and i'm not even
good at fighting but what i will say is
that
there is a very clear-cut
very very useful kind of night and day
uh learning experience from being
physically humbled
that's way better than being like
ridiculed like
every guy should i don't i don't want
people to end up in the hospital but
like learn talk [ __ ] get hit like if you
don't learn that
you know your whole life you're like
you're just gonna keep doing it
you know you're in a fancy area you know
santa monica palisades so i'm sure
everyone
no one's either just going to expect
they're going to sue you well it's like
for whatever reason i sent you a rogan
pictures and i post on my instagram
dude i saw four rattlesnakes crazy and i
was like what the [ __ ] is happening
one was big and it was like this cool
blue brown
dirt noodle uh dirt serpent what do you
call it a danger noodle
it was that's what i used to call myself
dude it makes sense dude it was big it
was like this big that one right there
and it was like a cool blue and there's
is it a rattler or is it something else
oh that's a rattler papa
wow he's are cool blue that's a
beautiful you hear me at the end she
goes thank you
whoa that's a beautiful isn't that cool
i love seeing them now they don't really
scare me but four of them was like what
the [ __ ] is going on
but you hear the lady watch she goes
thanks i got no problem
because she's she's coming right i see
these titties flopping right she's
coming
i see these tips like this she rubber
she makes she's impossible tits like
this
right and then i see the snake and i and
she's coming straight for it
and i'm like this she's like i'm like
this and she's like
and i i'm pointing like he's come he's
started at the front and she's gonna run
right into him
and i'm like this i'm all snake snake
and she goes she is what
are you there you don't see the giant
rally saying she goes oh they're
harmless i think
yeah all right she was so mad i
interrupted her jog i was like what the
[ __ ]
that's not true by the way they're
harmless i'm like oh you're a [ __ ]
okay i'm gonna tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[ __ ] oh